when I spoke to you for yesterday you
told me you had a 5H hour cut of Pirate
Radio and my my question is when can I
see it you can never see it no one will
ever see it but it's a funny thing with
Pirate Radio now I think about it I
think if I had written it now I would
have done it as a TV series sure you
know because actually it was very kind
of episodic and we should have done you
know one where they raid another boat
one where they start to drown one where
the electricity goes down um but it was
fun it was fun at 5 hours um but I don't
think for human consumption well you
never know I mean uh baz just released
his Australia cut on Hulu as a
miniseries so maybe maybe you want to
revisit that as a anyway that's just a
hypothetical so I read a few years ago
that Hugh Grant revealed nodding Hill
was maybe based on a friend of yours and
um I wanted to know if it's possibly
time for the truth to come out no uh you
know I wouldn't go to Hugh Grant for the
truth uh if if you're searching for it
um it was really B no it was really
based it was based on a kind of fantasy
I used to have I used to go for um
dinner every week with the same people
and have the same conversation and I
remember when I was an obsessive Madonna
fan I thought what would it be like if
at last I to walk in with with a woman
instead of just on my own with a warm
bottle of white wine and kind of so the
movie started with that kind of dream
scenario of what would it be like if you
could and and you know I was thinking
about Madonna and one of my friends at
that dinner was an obsessive Madonna fan
and the other one would definitely never
have heard of her so it was based on a
on a dream rather than on a on a fact so
it's the 20th anniversary of Love
Actually and
it's now become a Christmas classic you
know people love the movie I love the
movie and if it comes on it's it means I
have to keep watching when did you
realize wait a minute this film has
become something special to a lot of
people it it was it was when I started
getting texts from people I didn't know
very well saying we're watching it again
you know it was it it did take a while
and it it it's still a bit of a mystery
to me I mean I've Got a Theory I think
the reason people watch it again is they
can never remember what's going to
happen next you know normally when you
watch a movie you know they've robbed
the bank they're going to get in the car
drive away and then they're going to get
shot by the police whereas even I when I
watch Love actually don't have any idea
what the next scene is so I think it
kind of it's bearable to watch it again
because it's always surprising you but
you know it's a Once in a Lifetime bit
of luck when you make something
particularly Christmas I used to so love
watching Charlie Brown's Christmas every
Chistmas Christmas and white Christmas
every Christmas so I'm it's a real
little it's a real little boost for me
did you ever think the Andrew Lincoln
storyline might be a little too weird I
am very often told it's a little too
weird uh it didn't occur to me at the
time but you know times change um and I
remember someone uh once saying they
would like to interview me about it and
they would be focusing on the stalking
scene and I said oh I didn't know there
was a stalking scene and they said yeah
yeah no you know the Andrew Lincoln
that's like topnotch stalking so you
know I slowly but surely I've realized
what a dreadful mistake I made I don't
think it's a mistake as much as you know
it's a little different than the rest
but anyway there's a new 4k blue new 4k
release that's about to come out yeah
what are you actually most excited for
people to see on it well it is very uh
pretty now I mean it is interesting you
know one of the things I do like about
love actually is I love how kind of it
looks I think actually the kind of
texture of it is very is has a sort of
magic to it and we've really added to
that the 4K you know where there were
fuzzers in the background you can see
chandeliers and candles and everything
like that so I think it's just a sort of
general feeling that the movie somehow
got a little bit better that it's even
more cheerful than it was before that so
the grade is really lovely and then
we've also remixed it and that's fun as
well cuz you know technical things do
improve as time goes by if you can
imagine watching a brighter version of
White Christmas what joy that would be
you've directed you've written a lot uh
but you've only directed a few things do
you have plans for directing something
else or you no no I I I I found
directing quite tricky and I mean this
movie is a great example I wrote a movie
set in New York which is such a pleasure
for me but I would have felt really
insecure as a
non-american directing it and also you
know I'm getting old and S boy who
directed it is not only an American but
young um so I I think I'll always find
someone who's better than me now I don't
necessarily better than you I just say
different than you also I'm trying to
keep my weight down and when you direct
movies you have to eat a certain number
of donuts and bacon sandwiches and I
think that's you know that's a price to
pay I don't think people realize
actually the one thing is there's a lot
of food on movie sets not in the UK the
UK is a little stingy but in America
forget it whatever they call it that
service table it's it's the most
Dreadful Temptation making a movie is
like going to Willie Wonker yes it's
just sweets everywhere unless you're in
the UK I've done UK set visits and they
you're lucky to get a cup of tea no it's
true American movies are
better just on Craft service on crft
yeah right exactly so a lot of people
with Genie will not realize this is a
remake of something you made many years
ago and so I'm just I'm just curious um
how did it come about to remake this
well it's funny not long after I made
the original movie which is only an hour
long I thought this would have been fun
as a movie movie um and but you know
time goes by you have children and all
that kind of stuff uh and then just a
couple couple of years ago I thought I
will go back and look and my
circumstances that's about kind of you
know a sad Singleton who's just lost his
girlfriend um and I thought well I'd
love to make a movie about families and
Christmas and I can actually write a
really different movie I can set it in
America we can have a female Genie and
then you know the Dream came true and we
got Melissa so there was just enough you
know a lot of extra things and then I I
do love Christmas movies and a can you
know do another one um that makes me
happy one of the things about a film
where you have a genie and they can wish
for anything is it can get expensive
very fast yeah so how much in the
writing of this of the Remake are you
thinking we can't afford that so let me
not even write it you know what what
normally happens is you write a movie
and then people tell you you can't
afford it so I don't remember thinking
um I've GNA I can't do this or that and
then I think there were moments of of
realism you know we couldn't get a real
c um but I think that um on the whole my
my imagination's pretty modest so most
of it happens you know in a in in a in a
pretty realistic environment uh and then
once in a while they say you know change
a you know a Christmas Market to you
know a coffee store sure you have a
number of references to Tom Cruz in the
film and I'm curious did you need
permission when she's wearing that shirt
like how did that all come about we did
need permission from Tom and it was so
sweet that he gave it you know because
um there's an element of teasing um I
once worked tried tried to do a film
with Tom and he was always so delightful
and friendly to me and I don't know
whether the reason he said yes is
because you know he was so chummy then
but um I love the fact I love the fact
that I have eventually written a Tom
Cruz movie just so happens Tom's not in
it right exactly but he's on the t-shir
he's on the t-shir and we've got like a
three second clip from Mission
Impossible yeah when I saw that I was
like oh wow I mean you need permission
for this this is a you know what I mean
um so one of the things about this is
that it's more of a family film and I'm
curious um how did the balance of that
come about in terms of how much actually
let me skip that question Al together
I'm fascinated by the editing process
because it's where it all comes together
how did this possibly change in the
editing room in ways you didn't expect
or was this all Sam and you just saw the
finished film no no I mean it's
it's editing is my favorite part of the
process because it's just so interesting
you write a film it reads really well
you shoot the film you watch it you
think it's the worst film you've ever
seen um and it's really interesting um
and one of the thing you know how you
have to take out bits change bits stress
bits you know one of the great things
about Melissa in this is she's both
magical but very normal and the first
time I thought it I I about an hour in I
thought oh I've forgotten she's a genie
you know she's just a lovely woman and
then you have to build up put scenes
where she does magic closer together and
then the great thing about Christmas
movies is just the wealth of wonderful
Christmas songs you know you suddenly
can if it's getting a bit weak you throw
in the OJs or Otis reading or a bit of
anvil and suddenly the movie perks up so
no just like all my movies it was a bit
of a struggle but particularly because
the two leads well I say the two leads
and Mark Maron and Luise Guzman because
the cast was so strong we had very firm
foundations but as always it was a it
was a journey what do you think would
surprise soon to be fans of Genie to
learn about the making of Genie well I
think they shouldn't be surprised that
some of the funniest lines were written
by Melissa McCarthy and Mark Maron you
know I'm quite a tyrant in terms of my
own lines but these were really clever
Great American comedians uh and they
added you know they added stuff in um
and I think that you know I I think
everyone will perhaps be surprised how
convincingly American it is uh and
that's because because you know Sam's an
American director and so I hope that it
feels like a Richard Curtis movie but in
a whole new in a whole new world I am a
fan of your work have been for a very
long time I I'm obviously very curious
what you are working on now well
obviously I'm working on buying
Christmas presents um and decorating the
tree you know that's that's the big
stuff oh I've got a few things I've been
working on an animation which has been a
gripping process I mean it's the long
it's the longest film making in the
world but it's really interesting
because you write direct cast shoot and
edit all at the same time uh so that's
been very interesting to me and no I
think I might write a play really yeah
go on are you writing it now or it's uh
I've had a go I've started a couple of
them so I think that might be the next
thing I do uh the animated thing you're
talking about is called that Christmas
yes oh that's my that's my final outing
to Christmas by the way it's all going
to be it's all going to be Easter and
midsummer's day from now on sir you have
an addiction to Christmas I'm sure that
the play takes place at Christmas no no
there's not going to be any Christmas
I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
do delete all on my computer whenever
Christmas is mentioned again but I'm
hoping you know with Genie I'm trying to
go out with a bang oh no I think you
mean that Christmas you're going to go
out with a bang oh yeah yeah I'm going
out with a pre- bang on Genie
when actually is that coming out do you
know next Christmas because Christmas
has Tak so long so so a year from now we
will be talking again I hope so and you
will be talking about how the play all
of a sudden went to being take taking
place at Christmas yeah the play is will
be Christmas Carol by then right you
have actually done a tremendous amount
through your career and I am curious if
someone has never seen anything you've
done before what do you want them first
what do you want them watching first and
why Wow
what
a
um do you know the thing I really
like sometimes I go online and I find
that somebody who isn't me has edited
like my movies down to three minutes
with a really pretty pop song I think
start with that you know lots of pretty
people and no you know dodgy jokes I'd
go for Richard Curtis the Montage start
there got I'm look I'm very I think Four
Weddings is lovely and I wrote a TV show
called Black Adder and the final episode
of the final series of that is I think
an interesting piece of work so um there
are there are some things I like start
with Genie start with Genie of of course
last question for you which of the films
that you worked on or wrote do you think
changed in the editing room uh which of
the F yeah which of the films changed
the most in the editing room in ways you
didn't expect going in oh that's
definitely Love Actually strangely
because Love Actually was you know 10
stories and it seemed to work well and
it is in a completely different order to
what we wrote it in it's unrecognizable
from the original order even though the
scenes are the same it was like playing
three-dimensional chess because you
could put any scene after any scene at
any point that's definitely the one that
that's definitely the one that changed
my on that note sir uh I wish you
nothing but the best thank you for
giving me your time and good luck with
the rest of your speed dating that's so
sweet don't Don't Go Changing and Merry
Christmas right see you later from hor
and
H